You have to move into a new place,...
...so it's time to call all your friends and offer to buy them pizza,...
...if they'll just help get all your junk from here into here, then to here.
They all remember the last time you asked for help moving,...
...when they showed up and you weren't even done packing.
Everyone stuffed everything into their cars and it took all day.
That's not even worth a slice of pepperoni.
The secret to making moving a breeze for you and your friends are three simple tips.
First, no such thing as too many boxes.
Secondly, there's no such thing as too many boxes.
And number three, there's no such thing as too many boxes.
Seriously, packing is a breeze when everything is in a box.
Now, don't pay for them at the car rental place.
Get them from stores who are recycling them.
Here's a pro tip.
Liquor stores have perfect boxes for protecting glasses.
Start collecting weeks before you have to move,...
...and stop at every recycling bin that might contain a good score.
Now, pack everything up...
...and get that move done in an hour instead of ten.
Your friends will thank you.